foreign
comes from Thomas in Missouri as a
Christian I feel like I have a duty to
take care of my employees I have a small
business with nine employees they
currently make minimum wage if I were to
raise their wages to a living wage then
my profit margin would decrease this is
a business I worked really hard at for
so many years I think God would want me
to benefit from my hard work now what
should I do
uh okay
this is an onion here Dave
um number one
um businesses deal with this all the
time and when they when they raise wages
they have a decision to make do you want
your profit margin to stay the same and
so if so then you have to raise your
costs and you have to weigh that with
the marketplace and what your customers
will or will not pay and this is the
this is the dance that a lot of small
business people have to deal with and
have uh had to deal with and been heard
from it so I don't think it's a choice
here between God wants you to benefit
from your hard work now and you know not
doing what you want to do which is pay
your employees more I think you can do
both but you're going to have to
square raising some prices or cutting
costs in other areas if that's even an
option this is hard to answer I want to
say that everything I just said it's
very difficult to answer that via a
static question where we can't answer a
lot of questions excuse me ask more
questions you know the buzzword that's
the problem in this is living wage and
who determines that yeah well know I can
tell you who determines it me right
that's my point not what I'm saying no
I'm the employer here's the thing okay
if I pay
12 an hour
or if I pay whatever you want to
whatever minimum wage is in your area
okay and
um
a guy comes in and you do a budget on
the guy and he has five kids and uh he
needs ninety thousand dollars a year to
pay his bills and feed his kids
um I can't as a Christian hire him for
that job
because I can't pay him ninety thousand
dollars to do that job and ninety
thousand dollars for him is a living
wage because that's what it takes to
feed his five kids
okay if I have a
19 year old who lives with her his
parents comes in and is looking for
part-time work
and um any money he makes is going in
his pocket because he has basically no
personal overhead and twelve dollars an
hour is what I can afford as the
employer then that is his living wage
so this idea that there is a uh a
universal living wage is absolute horse
crap there is no such thing because it
takes some families it takes families in
different situations in different
locales a different amount to live it
takes a family of four more to live in
Manhattan than it does in Nashville
so the living wage would be different
for a family of four or a family of one
or a family of 14.
the living wage changes on that and so
what we do at Ramsey as Christians we
have a responsibility to take care of
our employees and one of the
responsibilities is not hiring someone
who can't afford to live on what we are
paying for that position
so you are disqualified if you can't
make it
on what we are paying for that position
regardless of if you want the job or
you're qualified for the job we will run
a budget with you because we care about
you and it is our responsibility once
you are here to make sure you are cared
for and we do take care of our team
beyond measure we take care of our team
that's correct way beyond measure we
take care of our team but we do not hire
people who cannot afford to live on
what we pay for that position yeah and
that is our responsibility that's your
responsibility so you know well you know
we have one lady go well you know based
on your inappropriate requests for my
personal budget information I'm going to
withdraw my name from future future
employment consideration to which we
said people that talk like that don't
even work here so we're not doing you
know it's great see you goodbye you know
don't let the door hit you in the butt
you know it's good you know we don't
need you and but you know but the reason
for the inappropriate request of the
personal information is to protect you
from you because some people will take a
job that they can't afford to live on
the income because they're so desperate
for a job right and uh so but this idea
that there's some kind of generic living
wage out there floating around that you
have a moral obligation to that's a
singer singular number is absolute horse
crap so uh you're paying minimum wage
for nine employees are any of them
trying to actually live on that with a
family if so why did they take that job
or why did you hire them into some they
can't afford to live on
and that's a bigger question then do you
raise your wages to meet this right and
here's the other thing you have to have
to look at your business model and the
market and go based on whatever product
or service I am selling because it's one
of the two this is what the market will
allow me to do and I may not ever be
able to truly have all nine of them on
what would be called a full living wage
you might be in the hourly space and
that's what you have and thus you've got
turnovery of younger people working for
it that's just part of your business not
a guy coming today instead of company
offered him eighty thousand dollars more
to do the exact same thing he's doing
with with us and we said fantastic we'll
help you pack your desk yeah it's a
no-brainer we cannot we cannot make a
return on paying you eighty thousand
dollars more than you're being paid now
so you uh you're gonna be working it's a
new place my friend and we'll help you
go
um because it is this you know we have
to make a return on investment here or
the rest of the team doesn't eat right
because their checks don't clear there's
a responsibility all the way around so
yes God would want you to take care of
your team and he would want you to
benefit from your hard work now these
are not incompatible that's correct yes
they're not incompatible that's correct
that's the point of it and don't fall
into this socialistic living wage crap
that was Karl Marx that was not Jesus
okay there's a difference